hi there steve kaufman here today i'm
going to talk about accents because
someone i can't remember where or maybe
on google plus or here at youtube asked
me
um
you know which accent should we learn
and it's a question that i get all the
time or which accent do i prefer uh and
so i want to take talk a little bit
about the subject of accents
um and i'm sorry that i don't plan these
out ahead of time but some of the basic
principles that that you know affect my
attitude towards accent is that number
one it doesn't matter
number two um
i guess we
will learn the accent
that we find the most attractive
or the most useful
or the most prestigious or for whatever
reasons that we have
or we'll learn the accent that we are
exposed to the most and it really
doesn't matter so if i go through the
languages that i speak starting with say
you know in order of sort of declining
order of proficiency
uh in case of french even though i grew
up in montreal
and i had french at school i didn't
really speak much french in montreal and
then i went to france where i studied
for three years so as a consequence i
ended up speaking more
like they do in france
uh when i am around people from quebec
my accent starts to migrate a bit a bit
and if i were to live in montreal and i
dealt on a daily basis with people from
montreal or from quebec my accent would
move more towards the accent of
people around me and i think that in i
have found at any rate that in our
in the languages that we learn as
opposed to our native language that we
are easily influenced by the people
we're speaking with in our native
language
it seems to be better anchored and our
our pronunciation doesn't change i mean
i've met obviously you know british
people living in canada who have lived
here for 50 years and their accent
hasn't changed some of them their accent
changes but most of them they don't
uh but when it comes to
uh a foreign language i find that i'm
influenced when i lived in france as a
student if i was down south pretty soon
i'd be starting to talk a little bit
like the people there
so i i think that the accent the
pronunciation that we have in another
language is never anchored quite as
strongly as it is in our first language
and so i mean i right now i speak the
way i speak because most of my contacts
have been with people from france and it
continues to be because i go to france
more often than i go to quebec
which should you learn obviously if
you're gonna i would think in the case
of french if you're gonna be living in
quebec you should learn the uh quebecois
accent uh if you're gonna be living in
france you learn the french accent if
you lived uh you know in the south of
france you'd to perhaps speak the way
they do i don't know
so then we get from there to japanese
uh definitely my japanese
while it's it's largely sort of
standard tokyo japanese because i in the
lumber business i had a lot of dealing
dealings with people from the kansai
from osaka
there are people who notice certain
kansai type intonations in my japanese
it's not a full-blown kansai accent but
they're certainly just by having spent
so much time with people
from the khan side that has influenced
my
japanese but i made no particular effort
to speak this way or that way i just
find that you you sort of pick it up
similarly with chinese my teachers were
from beijing so i have more of a beijing
accent but someone who lives in taiwan
or lives around shanghai will probably
pick up the accent there and it really
doesn't matter and as i say i think it's
quite fluid if you move to an area where
a different accent is used you'll
probably uh pick that up
spanish
again i learned most of my spanish in
spain and i happen to like the spanish
accent i like the use of the thu you
know so that a soft c
or a z is pronounced like a th sound
in south america they don't do that
i like the accent in mexico because it's
quite easy to understand it has a little
more of a sing-song in some ways it's
easier to understand than the more
machine gun
spanish in spain
but
i like having that
sound to hang on to because it tells me
whether it's an s or a c
and i've observed that a lot of people
in latin america make spelling mistakes
because they don't know whether it's an
s or a c so i kind of like the the sound
my wife doesn't like it at all her
mother was costa rican and she doesn't
like it when we go to spain and she
won't pronounce you know
uh
gunfall
she likes to say gonzalez
so it really doesn't matter it's
whatever you like while we're on the
subject of spanish no and i like the
argentinian accent i think it's kind of
neat to listen to it's got a real nice
cachet to it uh
chilean i find very difficult to
understand they chew all their words
but if i lived there i'd probably end up
speaking more like a chilean
so
and a lot of people sort of say well you
know in learning a language i only want
to listen to you know this form of
english and i think i've never had that
problem at all
i'm interested in learning words so i'm
listening to stuff that i'm reading i'm
using link to learn words and so in the
case of portuguese i couldn't care less
whether it was european portuguese or
brazilian portuguese in fact i
deliberately well mostly i listened to
things of interest but i also wanted to
be exposed to both european portuguese
and brazilian portuguese while learning
the words which are overwhelmingly the
same
and just so that i could in fact
communicate with both and i suspect
because my portuguese isn't very strong
that when i'm in
probably my portuguese accent is
influenced more than anything by my
spanish
so i speak a kind of portugal mixture of
portuguese and espanol
and
leaning a little more towards portuguese
pronunciation when i'm in portugal and
if i were to spend a few weeks in brazil
i would probably move in the other
direction
uh accents are interesting german for
example i guess i tend to speak more of
a northern german pronunciation i guess
closer to
obviously don't sound like german i
sound like a foreigner but
and yet but i like the bavarian accent i
like the uh austrian accent
uh
again as i say if i live there i'd
probably be influenced by it swedish is
an interesting thing with with access
like
russian which i have not
even though i listen to a lot of russian
i've got i probably have a bigger
vocabulary in russian than in swedish
but in russian i cannot tell
anybody's accent i don't know whether
they're from saint petersburg moscow or
kutsk wherever except if they're from
ukraine i can tell because the g is
pronounced like an h and that's about
the only thing that i can identify with
okay swedish
if when i'm in a certain area like
dalaina in sweden
or smalland and i spent a lot of time in
both dolena and smolland on my lumber
business
there you know smallant has an accent
dalara has an accent but the interesting
thing is that within dalana each village
has an accent and the same is molan so i
was at the 50th birthday party for one
of the people that we deal with on the
lumber business and a lot of people from
his village came to the birthday party
and i noticed that while they were all
speaking this small and accent theirs
was a little different so it's very
interesting how people living in this
little village will be influenced by
what they hear around them the same in
donna three villa or three different
towns mura lakes and uh
you know uh
what was the other town there i can't
remember
anyway my memory's gone but but
definitely the distinct accents within
the sort of micro accents within the
larger accents which i've definitely
picked up in swedish uh
almost more than anywhere else in
swedish i really really noticed it
so um yeah i don't think accents matter
that much it's
language is more about words and
vocabulary getting used to the language
and you're you can always if you
particularly like a kind of accent you
can listen to that and give yourself
sort of a
overdose of that accent and you will
migrate towards that accent people who
say that you know if you listen to the
wrong accent or whatever in your uh
early stages you'll never get rid of
that i don't believe that i find that
we're we're very very
easily influenced by the accent of
people around us
so
there's my take uh no real conclusion i
think people put too much
importance on this issue of accent learn
the accent you want to learn but don't
listen just to that accent
if you want to expand your your
familiarity with the language but if you
want to really train yourself to speak a
certain way then obviously you want to
find just that accent
and for learning purposes find a voice
you like and listen to content you like
and the more you like it the better
you're gonna learn
and that's all i have to say thanks for
now for listening bye for now